self-discipline is the center of all
material success I see self-discipline
as a really positive thing discipline
equals freedom 100 percent rise and
shine it's an espresso time what's up
believe nation at 7:00 my one word is
believe and I believe in you I believe
you have Michael Jordan level talent
adds something and I want you to find it
embrace it and use it to make a
difference so let's start your day off
right together grab your coffee and sip
on today's message develop
self-discipline over to you will Smith
so I do scream to me the other night a
will I want to be active man I will be
active just like you you know usually
people say stuff to me like that I'm
like yeah man you know you doing give
them an encouraging word but I was just
sitting here thinking and it dawned on
me 99% of people that say stuff like
that are not willing to do what it takes
to make their dreams come true the
Marines have a saying everybody wants to
go to heaven but nobody wants to die and
that's just real at the center of
bringing any dream into fruition is
self-discipline you know something
something as simple as food and eating
it is not about your your body as much
as it is about your mind it's getting
command of your mind to be able to
choose actions that are in your own best
interest every day we are choosing
that's not in our own best interest
right so if the world is attacking you
and the world wants to fight you in the
world's trying to hold you down so
you're gonna kick yourself in the balls
so you will stop yourself from getting
what you dream self-discipline is the
center of all material success you
cannot win the war against the world if
you can't win the war again
your own mind so I agree with Will Smith
I think it's a game of self-discipline
you know what you need to do and if you
don't know what you need to do you can
easily look something up but your
getting your own way it's the mind the
mind is getting in your own way if you
want to lose weight you know how to do
it you got to eat less you got to work
out more you will lose weight why are
you not doing it
self discipline your mind is getting in
your way what I see self discipline is a
positive I think self discipline has a
really negative connotation a lot of
times I think in a lot of the messages
that people are putting out it comes
across as this really negative thing
like you have to force yourself to do
all the stuff that you really hate and
it's gonna suck but you have to keep
going you got to do it you got to be
disciplined if you're not disciplined
you suck everything's terrible it just
comes across as this really negative
forcing yourself to do stuff that
doesn't resonate with me
I see self discipline as a really
positive thing I think it's really
helpful I think it's amazing and
beautiful and golden let's look at
weight as an example I am the lowest
weight that I've been all year I'm on a
routine it's working the specific
strategies that don't really matter one
intermediate fasting so I'll only have
water and a coffee until noon and then
after that I'll start eating I do that
seven days a week I run for thirty
minutes usually at night while I'm
watching the show with my wife seven
days a week and then six days a week
I'll restrict my calories not really
forcing myself not to eat food just not
eating Doritos and not eating junk right
eating healthy food six days a week and
then Saturdays I get to do what I want
six days a week those are the strategies
that I use it may seem like torture but
it's not and the thing that helps me get
through it is the mindset because the
positive of all of this is I'm losing
weight I'm feeling great I'm making
progress
I'm super pumped that I'm getting closer
to my goal I feel amazing about myself
so I think self-discipline usually it
seems to focus just on the action that
you just have to grind your way through
it without and not focus on the mission
of what you're trying to accomplish and
how beautiful and wonderful that is and
so yes some of it might suck right but
you're moving towards something amazing
and beautiful so I think people just
focus too much on the negative part of
it and
if you force yourself to do something
that you hate you can only do it for so
long before you give up if you can't tie
it into the bigger picture of what
you're trying to accomplish then you
will give up and you will quit and you
will feel terrible and then I think
having other people yell at you but how
you need to have self-discipline doesn't
actually help I think it actually makes
it worse because you develop the
identity for yourself of I don't have
any self discipline you can build it
it's not that difficult to do in my
perspective in my view all you need to
do is make sure that you have a really
strong why make sure that you have an
outcome that you are really looking
forward to and you love doing and then
the process itself how do you make the
process as enjoyable as possible how do
you make the process just not absolutely
suck every single day going in right if
you figure that out then you win at the
end of the day this is a mindset game
every single goal that you want to
accomplish is a mindset game the thing
that's holding you back is not your lack
of knowledge it's not your lack of
creativity
it's your mindset it's your it's your
perspective it's your view you can
figure out the answer to any question
quite easily it doesn't mean you will
execute it on it because your mindset is
broken nothing else you already have
everything you need to win and so
discipline is really important I just
try to tie it into some bigger picture
thing that I'm trying to accomplish that
is more important than any minor pain
that I have to struggle through in the
moment and that's high perspective I
hope it helps I'm maybe just a little
bit of a different bird on this one and
I'd love to know what you think now I've
got a really special bonus clip for you
that I think you're gonna enjoy but
before that question of the day what do
you think about self-discipline am I
wrong am i right I love to hear your
perspective leaving the comments below
thank you guys so much for watching I
believe in you I hope you continue to
believe in yourself a whatever your one
where it is much love I'll see you again
tomorrow morning for another shot of
espresso and enjoy the bonus clip
Spray so give me go
I love talking about discipline because
I think so many people that word has
such a negative connotation around it
right it just sounds bad discipline like
you're gonna feel pain or someone's
gonna hurt you or or you're in trouble
for something and I want to start having
you think about it in a really positive
way because discipline equals freedom
100 percent it has been the theme
throughout my entire life is how if you
have structured discipline in your life
and you start doing the things that you
don't want to do especially if you do
them first you are absolutely going to
free yourself of all of the different
pain that comes with not getting your
goals accomplished with comes with that
comes with not taking care of yourself
that comes with living with regret
so before way back in my early 20s and
even through my mid-20s when I would you
know I was trying to create habits
around maybe eating right or habits
around working out and let me tell you
habits around getting stuff done I
literally in my head told myself all the
time my mantra at the time was I never
finished anything so what do you think I
did
I finished nothing because that's
literally how I talked to myself well
well I never finished anything this is
another thing I didn't finish so I had
to switch that mantra around and it was
also realizing how important discipline
was and how much freedom came with it
and I spent a lot of time living in
agony in my head and I was tired all the
time because I spent more of my time in
my brain thinking about what I didn't do
and arguing with myself all day long do
am I gonna go to the gym I don't want to
go to the gym you should go to the gym
why aren't you going to the gym
you know you need to go to the gym
you're never gonna get to your goals
it's like I was drained just because of
the conversations I was having with
myself if I would have just gotten
disciplined committed to a time or knew
I was going I could have focused on all
of the other good things that were
happening in my life and just knew this
is what I'm doing it's like
saying okay well here's what I'm doing
so I can forget about it until the
moment that it comes I'm gonna do it
because I'm committing truly committing
to discipline and how freeing that is
and when I started getting a great
discipline habit around all of the
things that I wanted to do I started to
notice how much more free I felt how
much less anxiety I felt how when my
head hit the pillow I felt proud instead
of another day just went by that I'm
further away from my goals and I have
regret and I'm feeling my life race by
me right those are all feelings that do
not feel good that discipline can free
you from my guaranteed formula for
success that is 100% proven for my life
and other people have taught out work
out and proved out less and out
strategies again out work out and prove
out lasts out strategize what you're
looking on the screen here on the screen
look at those four again what you're
looking on on the screen here which of
those four things that you're looking at
the out work out improve outlets out
strategize which of those four things do
you think comes last meaning you'll
learn the latter the latest it's out
strategize why because that requires a
lot of experience it's like you got to
go through like a general in the war
right you got to go through so many
different words to learn different
strategies and what works and what
tactics works and what doesn't work
that's something you got to be working
on right however the other three out
work if a guy works 80 hours a week and
you work 40 hours a week you can't
compete with that guy if some if you
yourself are reading two three four
books a month and you develop in your
mind and your competitor is not and he
only reads one or two and you study in
industry articles and all the subs and
they're not you know you're studying how
to recruit CEO CFO CEO CMOS what is the
best way to stretch this million dollar
investment that I got to make this
happen who should I talk to to be part
of a group for mentors and CEOs group
and all these who should I network with
what community should I be a part of
who's the best engineers IT firm to hire
what are these competitors doing what
are some of the guys that are not even
in my market if you start studying those
industry somebody else isn't it's tough
to compete with you and in outlast some
people work 80 hours a week for a year
and that's great but they can't work 80
hours a week for three years some work
80 hours a week for three years but you
work 80 hours a week for five years you
outlasted the guy that the three years
are one year they can't compete
with you because the compounding effort
favors you so these four things that you
look at on the screen
require one thing and that's discipline
and the discipline part you don't hear a
lot about that's the things people doing
nobody else sees that's when you win if
you tell yourself a story long enough
you start to believe it won't you
believe it you act like I am Tulsa what
a whale out of handcuffs lightning
though Thunder in jail now you know I'm
bad on the last week I murdered a rock
into the stone hospitalized a brick I'm
so mean I make medicine sick the
fundamental key to success is it can
take between eighteen and two hundred
and fifty-four days of taking action for
a new habit to stick I've created a new
course called 250 for confidence or
every single day for 254 days I will be
sending you a video between 30 seconds
and 5 minutes long that you start your
morning with around making you feel
confident it's absolutely free check out
the link in the description below to get
access